لكن يا طاهر لماذا تركز كياف رغم متاعب
الحرب على ابقاء الضغط على القرمه الاجابه
تبدا من الرئيس الروسيبلاديمير بوتن فحاكم
الكريم المتهم من الغرب بالسعي لاعاده
امجاد الاتحاد السوفيتي تمثل له القرم
نقطه ضعف واضحه فمصيرها الى حد كبير مرتبط
بمصيره السياسي تلك الجزيره لطالم بقيت
بعيده عن الصواريخ والانفجارات حتى تحول
مسار الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا بعد سته
اشهر من اندلاعها تحديدا ما وقع عشيه قمه
الفيفا في اغسطس الماضي ولم يكن في حسبان
موسكو حينها ان كذا لا تدافع عن نفسها فقط
وانما تهدف الانتزاع القرمي مجددا فهي في
نظري كل منهما منهما اليهما مده تلك
الليله استوى على روسيا انا اوكرانيا تلعب
بالنار بل وتدحرج كورتها بضرب القمه تلك
الجزيره التي يصفها بوتن بان كل شيء فيها
يتحدث عن تاريخ روسيا وفخرها
[موسيقى]
اقواله عن القرم ليش هذا الهمم ويدعم
معنويات الروس يقول انها في قلوب الناس
وعقولهم كانت القرمود دائما جزءا لا يتجزا
ام روسيا لكن الرئيس الاوكراني
اساسا لانتهاء هذه الحرب باسرها مثل ما
خصص كلمته في بدايه العام على المنطقه
قائلا ان الحرب بدات بشبه جزيره القرمه
وستنتهي بها متعهدا الاستعادتها خطاب لم
يلقى اذان الروس الذين ما زالوا يعتبرون
ان اكياس تعيش اوهام السعاده
من بوتن هو خط احمر وقد يمثل نهايه نظام
وليس فقط نهايتها حرب صحيفه نيوز ويك
الامريكيه لخصت الموضوع استعاده القمه
تعني نهايه بوتانا
تتابع الصحيفه في مقالها نقلا عن مايكل
كيماج استاذ التاريخ بالجامعه الكاثوليكيه
الامريكيه ان خساره القرم ستبعد احساسا
مريبا لدى الروس بان بوتن غير قادر على
اداره الامور
وستضعفه بالتاكيد سياسيا يتفق معه محارب
قديم في البحريه الامريكيه يدعى شونس
ويؤكد ان مصيره بوتنه قد يكون اسوء من
فقدان وظيفته اذا سقطت شبه جزيره القرد في
ايدي اوكرانيا
في نظر البعض فقد يفكر الاوليغارش في
التخلص من بوتن اذا لم يستجب لدعوات
التنحي بعد سقوط القمه في كلا الحالتين
سيؤدي الامر الى هلاكه على احد تعبير
لديها ممتلكات باهظه كالفنادق والمنتجعات
والقوارب والمنازل والشركات حتى روسيا
الدوله نفسها ضخت مبالغ ضخمه لبناء الطرق
والجسور والموانئ فهذه الجزيره والحفاظ
عليها يعتبران كمتحانا يجب ان يجتازه بوتن
ولا فرصه للرسوب
[موسيقى]